[Music]
foreign
they are the world's greatest
Mercenaries
the only life they've ever known is war
the only loyalty they've ever had is to
each other
[Applause]
but the four on the left why don't you
take the two on the right and leave the
rest not the fast anymore oh here we go
the only thing faster light exactly
we'll see
oh
well I got three pieces of work to a
walk in a park one the hell and back so
we are working for the agency I gotta
Recon this island first the only thing
you need to know is a jobs reel and the
money's real
If this job to my friend here he loves
playing in the jungle right right this
problem
follow me please
people who fight back are killed now you
have a dying place maybe you can help I
don't think so probably I'd leave
[Music]
that's so funny
foreign
[Music]
counts
people live for terrible times but you
must believe you can survive
ten seconds you won't believe what's
gonna happen
[Music]
what happened to you got my ass kicked
with Wounded eyes
[Music]
are you crazy gonna kill me you're
welcome
I promise
[Music]
they're loaded
and I Pronounce You Man a knife
[Music]
today he's paying back
spawns of pure plutonium is powerful
enough to change the balance of the
World Imagine what five tons would do
[Music]
you're gonna need more men if you expect
to get out of here alive
I'm back
I can't let the contents of that state
fall into the wrong hands
plan track and find him kill him
thank you
how did you do that
shoe is bigger than his cars
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I can't be
we were close once we started this whole
Expendables thing together but we had a
falling out
[Music]
welcome the 21st century
I could do that
address and give it a shot
this is it this is your team
short notice
yeah very short
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Marty you should have killed me
where you had the chance
you want any kids
you were stupid enough to get yourself
into this space
you have to get you out of it
then take the stairs
how hard can it be to kill ten minutes
saying courageous but insane
[Music]
these guys
welcome home honey
do you read now what is this it's
classified
oh I'm sorry
you weren't invited
they call it bad behavior
hey why are you here I got this
situation when I need your help I need
bad friends
because I'm the new guy is that sniper
don't worry about it I got a
prescription
remember this face oh shoot it by
accident
terrorists have taken possession of
nuclear missiles on a cargo ship off the
coast
if these babies go off
it'll be world war three
to choose this life over friends
over family
It's Time to Get Loud
let's fly baby
[Music]
the reservation
that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
is that the biggest one you've got oh
it's way bigger than that
thank you
[Music]